de talent ainsi à washington des
étudiants en colère tentent l'impossible
changer les lois sur les armes à feu aux
états unis selon eux les 17 personnes
assassinées dans une école de portland
en floride ne doivent pas tomber dans
l'oubli
heiberg et la demande
je supplie dix survivants les gens au
pouvoir d'agir
mais hier les républicains de la floride
ont refusé de voter pour interdire les
armes d'assaut d'autres survivants de
parkland insiste sur l'urgence d'agir
combien de morts faudra-t-il déclare
cette étudiante avant que les choses ne
changent le président trempe a reçu à la
maison blanche
les parents de victimes des fusillade de
columbine sandy hook et portland
ce père a perdu sa fille la semaine
dernière il est enragée de voir ces
tueries se répéter en amp est la marque
à oued aïssi de ce jeune dévastée par la
mort de son frère déplore à quel point
il est facile encore d'acheter des armes
d'assaut dans notre chambre propose de
bannir le dispositif permettant à
certaines armes de tirer encore plus de
balles il suggère aussi d'armer les
enseignants dans les écoles où air
teacher avec schengen en m une solution
qui ne plaît pas à ce professeur
jusqu'où le président tiab ira-t-il pour
limiter la vente d'armes et jusqu'où les
membres du congrès le suivront-ils les
politiciens craignent de se faire couper
les vivres par la nr et le puissant
lobby des armes qu'ils financent leur
campagne électorale
si le passé est garant de l'avenir
républicains et démocrates feront très
peu pour protéger leurs concitoyens
contre ces tueries
vincent c'est ici christian latreille
radio-canada washington